in 44 jahren kamen klaus püschel so
einige leichen auf den tisch jetzt geht
deutschlands bekanntester
rechtsmediziner in den ruhestand
10.000 silber du ziert um etwa 30.000
untersucht die äußere leichenschau und
besuchen dann geschehen soll
dass er es diesen monat das krankenhaus
in hamburg eppendorf verlässt liegt auch
an der pandemie
märz für mich alles klar der nachfolger
war bestimmt und war dann klar
privatsender professor und läuft jetzt
aus und es gab klare überlegungen auch
das nicht so im juni/juli die aus dem
institut ausgezogen bin und dann die
letzten fälle noch bearbeitet und und
auslaufe und das ist eben ganz anders
gekommen wir sind tatsächlich nochmal
treffen gekommen dieser zeit doch trotz
seines großen einsatzes in der korona
forschung geriet der rechtsmediziner in
die kritik seiner aussage im mai die
infizierten wären alle auch ohne corinna
noch innerhalb des jahres verstorben
löst ein großes medienecho aus doch so
meinte er es nicht
das oberflächlich zu sagen und das hat
mir dann schon regelt haben dass einige
das so aufgefasst haben als seien wir
das schicksal der alten und kranken
gleichgültig das ist nicht der fall
müssen wir uns denn darüber sagen machen
dass eine zweite welle kommt die
unvernünftig sich in den nächsten wochen
und monaten die deutschen verhalten dass
gewalt nicht zu prognostizieren wirklich
wäre das auf jeden fall bei dieser
infektionskrankheit zu erreichen wie es
für ihn weitergeht vielleicht in nigeria
bei einem forschungsprojekt zu lassen
denn auch wenn klaus püschel sich ein
leben ohne tote sehr gut vorstellen
könne
sein interesse an der arbeit hören nicht
auf mehr nachrichten und welches nur
weil die schau dir hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren